- [Instructor] We're told that
Chloe takes a slice of pizza
out of the freezer and leaves
it on the counter to defrost.
She models the relationship
between the temperature P of the pizza.
This seems like it's
going to be interesting.
The temperature P of the
pizza in degrees Celsius,
and time T since she took it
out of the freezer in minutes.
As P is equal to 20 minus 25 times 0.8
to the T power.
So that's how she's modeling
her temperature of the pizza.
P as a function of time.
She wants to graph the relationship
over the first 25 minutes.
So what we're going to do
here is not so much focus
on the graph itself
although we will look at that.
I'm actually just going to
use a graphing calculator
in order to have access to the graph.
But I wanna look at the
graph in the context
of what we are trying to model
and carefully think about
what should be the labels
for the axes,
what parts of the graph are interesting?
So this is right
over here is this function
graphed on Desmos.
You can see I typed it in right over here.
P is equal
to 20 minus 25 times 0.8 to the T power.
Exactly what we had down here.
Now remember, this is
modeling the temperature
of our pizza as a function of time.
So to help us remember that,
let's put in some labels
for our axes.
So to graph, settings.
If I go down here, our x-axis.
Now our x-axis is really the T-axis.
That's our independent variable over here.
And what is it measuring?
Well it says it right over here.
It's measuring time T in minutes.
So we could write it like this.
T, which is measured in minutes.
And then, what about our y-axis?
Well this is really our P-axis
and that's measuring degrees Celsius.
So that's our P-axis,
and it's measuring degrees Celsius.
All right.
So let's just look at what
our graph looks like so far.
So there we have it.
We've put in our axes and we
have already typed this part
in so I can focus on the graph itself.
Now are we done?
Is this all we need to really think about?
Well the next part to
think about is the domain
and what part of the y-axis.
So what part of the range
are we really interested in?
Well the first thing to realize
is we're modeling something
as a function of time.
And so we really shouldn't
be having negative time here.
And we wanna think about the relationship
over the first 25 minutes.
So let's go back here.
And when we look at the range of x values
that we care about,
and really that we could think
about the part of the domain
that we care about,
we wanna restrict to x being greater than
or equal to zero.
And obviously in this situation,
x is really T and then we
can also think about it
as less than 25.
We don't have to restrict the upper bound,
but these are the first 25
minutes that she cares about.
So let's do it like that.
And now let's look at our graph.
And the important things
to appreciate is that we have the axes.
We can see them.
And so at time T is equal to zero,
we see that we actually
have a negative temperature
in degrees Celsius, and that makes sense.
It came out of the freezer
so it's below freezing.
And then we see that the pizza is warming
up as it gets closer and
closer to room temperature,
which over here,
looks like it's pretty
close to 20 degrees Celsius.
And so now it looks like
we have been able to graph
what Chloe is trying to look at.
It looks like we have modeled it well,
we have labeled it accordingly,
and we have set the ranges
of x values and the ranges
of y values that we'd wanna look at.
The y values we just wanna
make sure that over the range
of x values, and it's really a subset
of the domain not to confuse
the term range too much.
The subset of the domain of the
x values that we care about,
that we can see the
corresponding y values.
And we very clearly can see them.
And we're essentially done.
We've thought about how to best look
at the graph of this model.